le pourcentage du nucléaire et des
énergies renouvelables sur notre
investissement dans notre plan à moyen
terme je commencerai par dire qu'est-ce
qui est France et qu'est-ce qui est pas
France puisque j'ai eu cette question
tout à l'heure et je n'y ai pas répondu
je je m'en aperçois
aujourd'hui notamment parce que nous
sommes dans une phase de intense sur le
projet inclay point au Royaume-Uni qui
nous permet d'être au rendez-vous sur la
filière parce que s'il y avait pas eu ce
projet on ne serait pas au rendez-vous
aujourd'hui notre équilibre
d'investissement est 65 % Fran 35 % hors
France l'ensemble des enjeux de la
transition énergétique française vont
nous amener à 80 % France et le reste ne
veut pas dire que nous ferons moins à
l'international nous ferons différemment
c'est dire que nous sommes dans un
métier construction de production
électrique qui attire beaucoup
d'investisseurs mais qui a peu de
savoir-faire il se trouve que nous nous
avons le savoir-faire et donc nous
sommes capables de travailler comme nous
le faisons depuis longtemps mais on va
le faire à plus grande échelle
avec des co-investisseurs dans lequels
la côte part de DF est beaucoup plus
faible et donc c'est comme ça que nous
allons nous allons travailler